there we go
and welcome to everyone as you file in
from the waiting room
going to ask folks
as you enter can you let us know where
you're joining us from
always interesting to see
and
welcome everybody
and you can see that we'll be starting
in a minute and a half
this is a
preview of the Caltech
cyber boot camp
good warning shella
I just want to make sure it wasn't
Sheila showa
Nick from Sri Lanka
welcome
and
what about the rest of you who else is
out there where you where are you
visiting us from
Newton Massachusetts
Newton Massachusetts Newton Mississippi
I'm not sure I'm familiar with Newton
Massachusetts I'm not familiar with
Mississippi but but Ms so
you're from Jersey from malawian central
Africa
flooding
got several continents now
we won't tease the people from Jersey
too much
you're from Jersey
and
that tells us that the timers run out so
it's time to get the meeting started
give me a moment and I will do just that
let me turn off that
alarm
and share our presentation
one moment
all right thank you for your patience
and I am Stuart Creek I am with simply
learn where the delivery partner with
Caltech
Center for technology and management
education for the Cyber boot camp and
this is what we're going to be talking
about today with William Bailey who is
one of our senior instructors and an
expert in cyber security in his own
right and
will let Bill introduce himself in a
moment but first I want to set a couple
of quick ground rules about
how we'll do this webinar so everybody
put your questions into the Q a box uh
if you want us to answer those in the Q
a at the end of this webinar uh we are
recording the session we'll be sending
you a follow-up email with a link to the
recording and information about the
bonus offer that you get for attending
this live today uh it's an early bird
discount on
camp and we will let you request a proof
of attendance for this webinar if you
want a proof of attendance email to you
in the post webinar survey as you exit
please put your name in the appropriate
box and we'll send that to you
that said I'm going to start off by
asking a question
and this question is
for those of you in the audience how
much experience do you have and not in
cyber security per se but
are you still studying for your degree
or are you in the Working World
let us know
see some other folks checking in from
Virginia from Rochester
places around India
Maharashtra
and I'm going to leave this open just
for another three
two one hit that button
and
here is the result
so almost two-thirds of our audience in
fact it is two-thirds of our audience
who are currently studying
um and then people in the workforce make
up the other third so we'll share with
you how this program
works and how it can help you
um
first I'd like to
tell you about the agenda for today
and the agenda as you've seen we're
going to be asking a couple questions
about you along the way we'll talk about
cyber security and cyber security
careers
um which I assume is the reason why
everyone's here you're curious about
career and cyber security and how to get
ready for that so we'll talk about how
the Caltech boot camp
helps you and then we'll go into how to
join the boot camp and we'll take your
questions
live so Bill can you tell the folks
about your background
uh you know when I got into uh cyber
security or information security it
wasn't even really a field it was just
hey there's this technology stuff
and then over time we realized that we
had to start securing it so uh you know
at this point 20 years of experience
with information security privacy and
risk a big fan of you have to know what
you have in order to secure it uh I I've
worked various roles over the years I've
been in healthcare I've been in finance
I've spent some time with retail folks
utility folks government military folks
really cross-spectrum and we see that
cyber security affects everybody whether
they like it or not uh and uh the uh you
know currently doing a lot of Consulting
you know so I led a security program for
several years uh got organization
through the reviews every year uh made
you know had to stay on top of
everything that was
happening in cyber security and uh and
how to do it efficiently as well right
uh and uh yeah now just doing a lot of
Consulting and of course I've been an
instructor with simply learned for quite
a while and it's uh you know in
certifications I I have met very few
certifications I don't like
um although that's not the emphasis of
this boot camp
um I do come with that experience of
knowing oh by the way this is what all
these other certification bodies have
been looking for over the years
thank you
um
yeah
we'll I'll introduce simply learn as an
organization
um
simply aren't is the number one online
boot camp in the world for digital
skills for digital the digital economy
we deliver all of our programs strictly
online and that means that you can
access them anywhere in the world we've
helped five million professionals
worldwide and 130 150 I'm sorry
countries
um
become more proficient upskill move
higher in their career sometimes make a
full career pivot so we've been doing it
for 13 years and we're very very uh
pleased
to be the partner with Caltech they
chose us to deliver this program with
them and
very proud of that fact
we're going to talk now about cyber
security and the careers in cyber
security and so
why is cyber security such an essential
part of our world today
well cyber security has became an
essential part of today's economy
because technology transformation has
invaded well and I don't even want to
say economy I just want to say life uh
because I mean what was it last week I'm
looking at my refrigerator and I'm
realizing that the refrigerator has you
know RFID for the water filter and it's
monitoring all these characteristics
about it and you know that's the the
basic model that doesn't phone home over
the internet but so much of our devices
now phone home and we're doing a lot of
self-service it's all Technology based I
mean technology transformation has taken
hold and with it yes we have to secure
it yep and you know there is a recent
article about you know whether ring
cameras the the remote monitored uh
web connected camera that you can put on
your your doorbell or on your front door
uh whether that's a good thing or a bad
thing but it's a real thing and and
these kinds of devices are pervasive you
know our cars have multiple sensors in
them and the sensors collect information
and in any cases the information
sent back to logged by the car the car
manufacturer for updates and maintenance
and that type of thing so
the things that it's not just the phone
that we have in our pocket is that it's
the connects us constantly to the
digital world
oh that reminds me we just had prime day
uh you know the last two days yes and of
course one of the things that's showing
up today there's going to be a little
Smiley box and it's going to have this
uh air fryer toaster oven pizza maker
and it comes with an app yeah and that's
the way you control it is with this app
and it knows how to do everything but
you know it's going to be connected to
the internet and it's going to be using
a cell phone all the time yep yeah and
it's a
everywhere you go in every aspect of our
lives especially since the pandemic we
are connected in some way and we
interact with
Digital World
um and much of that interaction isn't
just on whatever device we're talking to
um but it's an interaction that then
connects that device and us to the rest
of the world and that means there's so
many different
places that malicious people could
attack us right
well there's so many uh touch points you
know we've taken the attack surface and
it used to just be everything at home
was isolated and your car was isolated
but now everything's connecting your
your phone is tracking you because we
all subscribed into Google and yeah
we're using the Google services and
Google knows where you were and and
Google's been tracking us for years so
you look at something and it says you
last visited this February of 2018. how
did you know I was there in February
2018. that's a little creeped out
yeah and of course we're all familiar
with the phenomenon of you know you were
talking to your spouse about a
particular place you might want to go on
vacation or particular thing you might
want to buy and suddenly start seeing
the ads popping up on various social
media sites and other other places
um so
this means that
an organization that wants to protect
itself not just the individual who wants
to protect him or herself but
organizations have to consider all of
the connected devices all of their
employees smartphones
um the machines that are part of their
network
servers the networks themselves
everything that
comprises the Enterprise's digital
footprint so
this is a survey from
pricewaterhousecoopers in 2021
of cisos and cios
and it's interesting that half or more
of the respondents at that time said
they hadn't fully mitigated their new
cyber security risks especially in the
wake of uh
digital transformation shift to work
from home
introducing new non-contact business
methods is that a surprising number to
you
no I'm actually kind of happy that half
or more of the csos and cios admit that
they haven't fully mitigated uh their
the new cyber security risks because
these risks are changing all the time so
you can't just uh you know you can't
just say okay I've done everything I'm
done now yeah it's you know like this
year has been the year of AI and you
know a year ago where we say is AI on
everybody's playing card wasn't there
now it is yeah and and that's an
interesting thing because
um with the example of AI of course
we've been thinking about AI
um for
a century or more
um
in terms of the idea of robots and smart
machines and intelligent Androids and
that type of thing but the real world
application of AI
um that burst onto the scene with chat
GPT uh is just fascinating because it
takes it out of the realm of Science
Fiction into your your desktop and
AI itself you know that poses a cyber
security risk in certain ways so you
need to understand
you know all the new technologies that
are coming out
look at mobile you have to look at the
internet of things you have to look at
Cloud as you know
expanding this environment you talk
about the castle wall or the moat
um can you kind of expand on that a
little bit
well I laughed when I saw that uh
advertisement in the Super Bowl with the
Trojan horse breaking in
reality for security and you would have
this big fortress and you'd put your
fences in your moats right Your Castle
your moat uh you'd have your big strong
walls you've had for your big viewpoints
looking down and then just everything
was inside but now uh well we've got all
this technology that's reaching out
anyway so you've got all your Internet
of Things devices you know you mentioned
the ring cameras a few minutes ago how
about your uh automatic uh I don't want
to say the vendor but vacuum cleaner
that's that's trying to map out your
home or your Castle right because you're
homeless Your Castle so the vacuum
cleaner is mapping out your castle and
the uh and it's not using encrypted data
it's phoning out
um it's just the and and of course
everybody has left the castle because
now everybody's in their own personal
castle and so yeah we don't bring people
into one Castle people are working from
anywhere and so it's just that that
castle mentality doesn't really exist
anymore
right I mean you used to to talk about
controlling
the uh organization's assets within the
boundaries of the organization but March
2020 we all moved out of those
boundaries
and the organizations didn't necessarily
keep up with providing that expanded
network of security to people who are
starting to work from home so
um the other thing that's on the slide
that's interesting is that
um
we
aren't in a world where people spread
computer viruses as a joke anymore they
spread it as a way of
how they earn their income and that's
that's a kind of a scary world to live
in isn't it
well yeah you know the the you know the
the bullet point talks about the nation
states and you know we still see nation
states taking action uh you know one one
nation against another various political
factions taken action uh to take down
you know cyber warfare
I you know Russia Ukraine we're seeing
it there
um the uh but you know the Cyrus
criminals well they're successful
because it pays for itself and they will
actually have whole call centers
customer service centers that so it's
easy it is literally cyber crime as a
service yep and and it's very
sophisticated they are paying very close
attention to cyber security from the
uh Bad actors side and so it's important
for organizations to pay attention from
the defensive side and
you know as this ciso the first quote
you can build a reputation over decades
but one cyber incident can ruin your
entire company reputation almost
instantly so this is this is the kind of
risk that companies run right
but I am surprised sometimes how
T-Mobile can survive after all of the
breaches that they announced it seems
like one at least one a year uh yeah and
actually there was one that just uh was
announced this uh this week TIAA
apparently is now at a breach
uh so a large retirement community uh
and yeah it is and that's an organ
it's because they serve the educational
community
so that they're going to be a bit
conservative when it comes to their
retirements and Investments and now you
people are putting their faith in this
organization expecting their you know
that organization to be with them for
basically their whole lives and it's
going to be interesting to see how that
plays out with Tia's reputation yeah
that's the teacher's retirement
investment uh organization that
um
Bob Mueller of the FBI
uh made a very wry comment
either you've been hacked or you're
going to be hacked
um is it really as fatalistic as that
I I it pretty much is it's really have
you been hacked already or you know uh
or have you been hacked and you don't
know it yet that's that that's the other
middle category that he you know kind of
didn't really call out here uh and yeah
we have to look in cyber security for
the malicious Outsiders
but we also have the Insiders sometimes
and you know they could be accidental or
they can become disgruntled insiders the
the workers that we've given access
we've let them into the castle and they
decide that they want to take the
information with them yep
and so as India country says
we all depend so much in our digital uh
ecosystem that we live in that if we
don't feel that our computer's safe that
we don't feel that we're personally safe
it's part of our
General and even personal well-being
right
the the cyber security Market
uh in 2023 is estimated to be a
175 billion close to 175 billion US
Dollars and the compound growth growth
rate is about 11 which means that by
2027 you'll be looking at a market
that's over 260 billion dollars and
continuing to grow do we see any sign
that that's slowing down
no
everybody's buying the latest technology
everybody's doing digital transformation
and every time you know the Cyber
criminals have already gotten their
foothold that they're like I said
they're basically making they're
supporting themselves at this point with
their malicious efforts uh so I don't
see that shrinking or tapering off
anytime soon at all there will be it's
one of the few Fields where you know it
will always increase it's not like
there's going to be a magic pill that
will take care of cyber security in
medicine we might have one but not in
cyber security yeah and because the
evolution of uh people human beings is
much slower you can be more reliable uh
rely more on the fact that if you cure a
disease that you've cured it for quite a
long period of time for everybody but if
you have a disease that affects your
cyber environment it's going to evolve
in some new form of
rhetoric virus is going to come out some
new method of attack some new
vulnerability in the new technology
that's instituted we talked about chat
GPT and where did that potentially
provides
opportunities for Bad actors
the the number of people worldwide that
need to work
build these cyber security jobs and
protect people companies and people
against these threats
pretty vast and the United States talks
about
almost a million professional positions
for cyber security
of which about half are not filled
and then um looking ahead a couple just
a couple years worldwide 3.5 million
job openings and cyber security
are these numbers surprising to you
yes it makes a lot of sense that you see
these numbers because you realize that
people come into the industry but people
also leave they move on they retire
and we're we're seeing the the growth
especially you know covid-19 and we saw
that growth of everybody working
remotely and so we're still playing
catch-up uh in filling those roles to be
quite honest
there you go
the the interesting thing and this is a
US oriented boot camp so I'm using uh
U.S salaries sourced from Glassdoor but
if you look at cyber security
engineering careers
um 100K is a typical uh salary
ranging up to 156k or more
and if you become a cyber security
architect you increase your salary range
by about 50 percent so are these
reasonable to you are you seeing
salaries of this type or
low or high
um so every so often I you know you will
see some salaries that are even lower
than what's listed here and I was
talking with someone I think it was
Tuesday they were telling me about some
some uh salaries that were you know they
were taught they were saying well we've
heard about 60 to 90. I'm like well okay
actually 80's right in the middle so you
know it's that's about right
um and I said oh so when you have your
job for three months you'll probably be
making 90. they go yeah so these were
people with like zero experience yeah
um and and the the upper end of this
even higher and that's the that's the
thing that's really uh interesting is
that you know if you you say okay this
is a cyber security engineer but you
know if you are a cyber security expert
you may take on that CSO role that we
talked to ciso earlier and some of those
folks yeah they're 250 400 600 more uh
you know and uh those the demand is
soaring for those roles
I appreciate that it's a
it's a place where you can build a
career it's a place
where you can build a career I mean
here's here's from a Glenn Glassdoor
some of the companies that are hiring
and these focus on large organizations
but
pretty much every kind of organization
every size of organization
needs cyber security so
you might work for one of these
companies directly or if you're accent
you know going to work for Accenture PWC
or that type of thing you might be
designing cyber security uh for other
clients right
oh absolutely you know you look at
Lockheed Martin you know they're going
to do work on behalf of other
organizations Accenture you know and
they could be Private Industry or it
could be government military
absolutely yeah
yeah and of course the financial sector
extremely sensitive to cyber security
very vulnerable and an area that really
needs a lot of people in that area so
these are examples of some of the
companies hiring and and to get hired
you need to have
um
a pretty well-rounded background before
you start
thinking of
focusing in a particular specialty right
well yeah you kind of um before you dive
deep you have to understand how the
pieces fit together and so I like
someone could be uh they try to be a
penetration tester
um but they say well I you know they
could do penetration testing but they
don't understand uh how to respond to
that incident that they just helped
stimulate this is an example
yeah and um so you need to understand
you know where the vulnerabilities are
how to identify them what the principles
are of how people would attack those and
then you go into learning
both how to be an attacker so that you
can think like the people that threaten
your system but also how to be a
Defender and think of how you would
detect and
neutralize those threats so it's it's
kind of an interesting field for people
who are problem solvers who are kind of
excited about
Game Theory and that type of thing and
there's a lot of different potential
roles you know just talked about the
attackers and the red team and talk
about the Defenders on the blue team and
then the people who who build
infrastructure or build applications
the
are there other roles besides these that
you would highlight
well I mentioned earlier that the
stethos those are the Chief Information
security officers we're seeing Chief
technology officers uh ever so often we
see some privacy folks who come in from
the cyber security side of the house
because privacy concerns uh are
affecting a lot of these organizations
and uh you know you have to understand
the technology not just the laws
yeah I mean one of the concerns about
chat GPT for example is uh people at gbt
and Dolly
people
who create original material that then
gets absorbed into these AI
knowledge bases are concerned about
their
um
intellectual property rights
so if I'm an artist and I've painted a
picture and Dolly takes that picture and
uses it uh in
generative adversarial Network to create
a whole new picture that still has
recognizable elements of what I've done
don't I have any right that you know
derivation isn't that a copyright
violation that type of thing there's a
lot of that kind of of thought about the
text part as well
go ahead you would think so but usually
a lot of these Services say we have the
right to use your data
it and it might be buried in the terms
and dis terms and conditions or the
disclosures which
everyone
reads yeah of course nobody reads it
everybody yeah we all spend hours
pouring over the 15 pages the 50 pages
of uh disclosures and and uh eulas for
every service we sign on to Yes
um and it brings up the question of you
know what if somebody's picture got
uploaded and they didn't know about it
necessarily get permission in the first
place and then suddenly it's being
adapted uh deep fake being an example of
that so there's
you know all sorts of interesting things
about privacy about security about uh
that aspect of cyber security in
addition to the threats and attacks
um
here's a poll question for the audience
so we're assuming that you're all here
because you're interested in the
potential of a career
in this field
and
we'd like to know what has stopped you
from choosing a program up to this point
why haven't you signed up for uh
certification program qualification
program is it because you're looking for
something that's fully comprehensive you
haven't found that as it because
you're worried about having results from
the program that you can use as
practical examples
is it because of the style of teaching
doesn't fit you or is it because your
work schedule your school schedule has
prevented you from finding the time so
I'll leave this open for another 10
seconds
make more than one answer
please hit the submit button and I will
close in three
two one
and
the overwhelming concern that people
have in our audience today is finding a
program that gives you practical
experience at the end of the program you
can point to things and say this is an
example of how I use this tool this is
an example of how I solve this problem
and be able to
proof examples to the people and then
finding a comprehensive program finding
when the
it's in your schedule those are also of
concerns
so
let's talk about this program in that
context
the cyber security boot camp from
Caltech ctme
is a comprehensive curriculum it's
aligned with the industry's requirements
the reason Caltech has a center for
technology and management education
because of all the companies that have
come to them over the years and said you
people do amazing work and research and
development of Technology can you teach
our people how to use some of those
skills and so they listen to what the
companies require for positions and
design their curriculum around that so
this program and Bill you have
experience with this program in
the instructor
um
combining the
live virtual classroom where you work
with the students and the integrated
labs and Hands-On projects so you're
working with them on the that
lab platform during classes as well as
having them do work between classes yes
absolutely yeah we basically uh spend oh
my gosh the percentage would be pretty
high I'm you know sometimes we have to
have some slides just have to but then
we're right there we're at a terminal
we're running these programs we're
showing how to work these programs uh
and we do it in a style where we will
walk through
a series of steps and the Learners are
doing the similar types of steps in a
different scenario so this is how we did
it once now you everybody's seen it once
in this way now you have a different
exercise but you're going to use the
same commands you're going to use the
same switches you're going to like
logically you you you watch it you learn
it and then you apply it uh and and you
know you're either applying it uh as
part of the class time or it's one of
those homework things that okay we've
done it now you can now do it and you
can take as much time as you want so you
don't feel that time pressure as well
sometimes yeah and then
because the platform is online and
because it's available 24 7 that means
that the learner can use it anytime that
they find hours in their schedule and
time whether it's an evening or the
morning before their workers classes or
weekends
you have the ability to to pick out the
time that's available to you to do that
work and when you're doing the labs and
projects you're creating artifacts that
go into your portfolio so that you end
up at the end of the program with a
number of examples of how you've used
the different tools and solve the
different problems so that's really one
of the best parts of this program isn't
it
well absolutely and that's one of the
challenges sometimes people say oh I did
a boot camp but you know then someone
says what experience do you have and you
know you're completing these projects
and you're uploading these projects uh
and they're getting evaluated they're
getting uh you know graded if you will
um by trainers such as myself and so
yeah that's in your portfolio when it
comes time to look for employment and
that's something that even after even
after you've had experience for a while
you still want to have some samples
ready there are a lot of firms who are
asking for these samples and so here
you're doing a program you're learning
material and you're getting the samples
that you're going to put in your
portfolio absolutely yeah
the end of the process you walk away
with that portfolio but you also walk
away with a certificate from Caltech
that certifies that you've completed the
core courses and to their satisfaction
um
you have
King receive up to 26 continuing
education units from Caltech if you're
in the job or in a field where you have
to provide that proof of continuing
education either to your employer or to
a licensing body
um you also get membership in the online
Caltech ctme Circle so you can Network
on a lifetime basis with people who have
taken other Caltech ctme programs either
this one or other
programs offered by ctme and so you've
got a lifelong industry networking
opportunity access the programs that
Caltech makes available to the circle
members and you'll be invited to an
online convocation where you'll be
recognized by name
for your accomplishments these are all
things that are tangible results of the
of the program
we talk about Caltech I mean Caltech is
is a very prestigious Institution
are you how do you view that
relationship bill
I you know the you're you're attending
this program hopefully everyone chooses
to attend it because we obviously
um but it is it's the home and alma
mater of many Nobel laureates it's
and it does mean something it's uh that
that you could say yes I've taken a
Caltech program uh you know it's not
just I took Bob's computer course you
know I'm going to exaggerate a little
bit but to drive from the point that you
know uh the job description will say you
know what education have you had but you
know you're saying oh I I went to a
Caltech program that actually it carries
more weight and you may know somebody
who went to Caltech or I want or I
wanted to go to Caltech that's great and
you know it just sort of there's that
halo effect that also carries on to you
because there is that recognition of yes
we know Caltech yep everybody uh
nowadays I think Associates Caltech with
the TV show The Big Bang Theory and the
reason that they picked this as the
setting for that show is because they
wanted to talk about uh the quirks of
very brilliant people and Caltech is one
of the highest concentrations of very
brilliant people in the world so
um
we're very proud as a company simply
learned to be associated with them and
we're very proud that they chose to
associate with us for the delivery of
this program
um this program is
uh
fairly wide open almost anybody as long
as you have that basic understanding of
math concepts programming Concepts do
not have to be a mathematician a
statistician or a seasoned programmer
but you do have to have a basic
understanding aptitude in those areas
um as far as the educational
prerequisite anyone with a high school
diploma who's at least 18 years of age
can qualify from that standpoint and you
do not have to come into the program
with work experience
um
how does work experience
factor into this boot camp do you see
that as a kind of a nice to have or is
it really something where people can
come into the program
just
fairly new and as long as I've got the
aptitude for it
well you know yeah this uh you know GED
work experience
um it doesn't hurt uh it doesn't hurt if
you have prior experience uh and you
know sometimes those are the folks who
you know in the first like week or two
you see them just like take off and
you're like oh okay you're gone uh
you're you're rolling with it now that
being said those people who have an
aptitude and the ability to like you
don't have to program but you have to be
able to understand logic and if you
could not follow logic then you can
learn everything else
and and that's where you know that's
where these labs and of course the fact
that the lab is available 24 7
um you know so that that's what's great
about the online environment also is if
you you know if you say oh I don't have
the work experience I have the aptitude
I want to do this I'm excited to do this
you know that online environment gives
you that opportunity to take the extra
time so remember those folks I said in
the first week or two they're like taken
off well what happens is those people
who don't have the work experience you
know they put the time in in the online
you know the 24 by 7 they make use of
our slack they make use of the office
hours that we make available and we
could do like a half hour call as an
instructor we'll do a half hour call
with someone and we'll sort of put them
on a path and like the light bulb goes
off and then they go off and they finish
yeah and they they work you know take a
few more steps and you know by the time
we get that couple weeks into it at that
point now that that work experience is
sort of really subsided that that
initial boost is subsided yeah and the
the platform includes a lot of other
Rich resource materials including videos
ebooks code samples things like that
that help people
um achieve
and do that kind of
self-study for catch up in between the
live classes so
um can you kind of
walk us through after the induction
session which is the online session
where people learn how to use the
platform where to find their classes and
so forth can you kind of walk us through
how this program's built so that it
builds up people's skills from the
ground up
absolutely you know the first the first
few days you know we induct you into the
program we all level set we we learn
what we learn we learn what we know we
learn more about the people that we're
going to be a cohort with uh for the
next several months uh you know three
night usually three nights a week for a
lot of the a lot of the cohorts uh you
know three nights a week for three hours
a night
um you learn about each other and then
we learn about cyber security
fundamentals which helps us understand
why it's important um and that's the
course that like sometimes even if you
didn't stick with the rest of the
program like everybody everybody should
take that
um and it really sets the tone and lets
us know what we're going to learn
uh and then we go through and for a lot
of people asset and inventory management
you have to know what you have you have
to know how to maneuver around it
and then you know so we get you
comfortable with that those command line
type of uh utilities
um that you you're going to use in a lot
of the other security appliances in a
lot of the cyber security field
and then we move into networking and uh
understanding how the networking Works
uh and we start to move into programming
with python and you could if you don't
use Python after this program it's still
part of the curriculum right uh and and
it helps so like say you want to do go
or you want to do roster you want to do
Java or whatever you're understanding
the concepts of logic
you know and then as we you know we move
on to you know we system administration
which is sort of like bringing us back
around full circle sometimes because we
talk about the importance of
administering these systems and then in
the last two uh modules of the
curriculum we talk about the ethical
hacking approach the red team uh type of
attacking methodologies
um and then we also talk uh that we have
a module on the blue team or the defense
of methodology so you're actually
getting to learn both sides of it and
the way it's placed is we don't throw
you right into attacking a system you
understand the concepts uh and so
conceptually when we get to that point
it's a much easier transition yeah
it's like you don't get thrown out of
the airplane until you understand how
the parachute works
um speaking of which these are the tools
that uh the program employs not entirely
comprehensive list but these are some of
the tools
and as
as Bill described when you're going
through a live class
uh the instructor's taking you through
how you use
particular tool for a particular problem
and how to
deploy it how to use it and to solve the
problem
and then you have access to those tools
available to you to do your independent
project so all of this is through a
virtual online environment that's
available to you on that 24x7 basis
right so you don't have to buy or
download any
additional software
No in fact I could actually fire up the
lab and show the actual lab it's fully
functional lab
yep and we'll ask you to do that in just
a moment
um before just before we do that I just
want to point out part of the thing that
bill is going to show you in this
environment are the support tools as
well so we build an ecosystem to support
it's not just having a health function
it's not just having a community
bulletin board function but it's also
our program manager who interacts with
Caltech and make sure that we are
delivering the delivering the program to
their requirements so you have a manager
for the cohort everyone who joins on the
same date as you
becomes part of your cohort and we have
an assigned person to help keep you on
track
make sure that you get what you need to
succeed
of course the instructors like they'll
help you through in the individual
modules and courses
and you have the support of your fellow
Learners so your peers in the course are
going to be another source of support
for you as well as the curriculum and as
I mentioned the rich resources that are
part of that so this is all
an ecosystem to help you succeed in
best opportunity
complete the course successfully
the this now would be where I'm going to
stop sharing my screen and allow bill
take us through the Live Lab
all right
let me share my screen here
they say sharing is caring exactly
okay excellent
so all right so the learning management
system
um you know you log in you type your
username and password you log in
and um yeah you see you're you're you'll
have your particular program here
and I believe if I clicked right I left
it here uh here are the actual courses
and someone had to act uh or the modules
if you will and uh someone had said uh
is Network systems part of it absolutely
you have the network systems right there
uh and uh all those modules that we
talked about those literally they are
the modules cyber security fundamentals
asset Inventory management Network
systems live programming system
administration red team inning and blue
teaming right and and you'll notice here
that the certificate
um each one of these actually has its
own certificate
uh that you can unlock as you complete
each one of these individual courses
that make up the overall program when
you complete the all of the all the
modules all the courses then you have
the actual certificate and the online
convocation that we that uh Stewart
talked about earlier
uh there are some electives uh that you
know and actually these office hours we
pretty much uh these don't have
certificates because I'll actually show
you
um in slack which we use as our
communications platform
um you can just click a link and you can
schedule a time uh and uh project hours
there is a course uh actually I have Pro
projects through all of the courses uh
that we go through so let me hop into uh
one of these courses here let's just
pick one uh asset and inventory
management and I'm going to click on the
self learning
and uh so my you know got to resize the
windows every so often there uh as
you're going through uh the course
material uh
you'll go through and uh yeah there we
have that expanded out
um okay we look at our self learning
there it goes right uh you have it's all
broken down into modules they're small
modules so they're easy to digest and
they're easy to fit into your schedule
so you can read these in advance to the
class
uh now all these and all of these
activities uh will tell you what
commands you're going to use and then
this is the series of of exercises uh
that you'll complete in the practice lab
uh and I mentioned the certificates you
see right here the certificate in this
case it is locked and that's just
because
oddly I don't attend as a trainer I
don't get marked for attendance so
therefore I I have not completed the
class even though I teach it
um and uh you have to complete all of
these so it's not just the simulation
tests uh but it's also completing the
project uh so there'll be a whole series
of steps that you'll have to go through
uh to complete this uh to to complete
the project
and uh to unlock that certificate and
move on to the next course
so here uh is whoops there's the lab and
I fired up the lab earlier because I
wanted to make this easier you know sort
of I feel like Martha Stewart sometimes
or you know the Julia Childs used to be
look here's our here's our souffle
that's already made
um and so like Zen math I picked on uh
because that's one of the things that
you know you're using zenmap and nmap as
as some of the tools burp Suite
um and this is a real functioning lab
out here uh and so literally you know I
fired this lab up uh when the webcast
started I told it to go look at our test
Network here this is a real life network
with real life systems that you can work
with and manipulate and this continues
through the courses so like there's a
python lab there's the ethical hacking
Labs there's The Blue Team Labs you get
all of those labs uh throughout the
various courses so you're getting you
know in the self learning you have the
you know literally it will walk you
through and when if I look at the
exercise here uh
you can
they'll have you work through some
practice steps here and this is actually
the Zen map uh that actually tell you to
go through and to to run uh and I did it
a little bit differently like I said
right so I did it on the 10.10 network
here you're doing it on the
172.16.8 network
um so you're getting to see that twice
again that I talked about earlier
uh and uh let me see if I've missed
anything important here just looking
around because there's so much here
um you know you've got the self learning
you're going to meet together as part of
your live class
um now I said like I said my attendance
is not actually tracked uh so normally
your class recording would be there we
encourage everybody to attend live but
we realize that life happens uh somebody
walks up to you and you just have to
take that phone call or you just have to
do whatever it says that they said they
wanted
um so your recordings are here so you
can go back and listen to them uh and so
you've got to pass classes that you can
go back and and watch those recordings
uh that and that's unique to the cohort
this is this is not like you're watching
pre-recorded video this is literally you
know I would be watching the class from
you know last night right it would be it
would show up here in that 24 to 48 hour
time frame so I would be watching the
class that we just had all right
um so ins for the community
um and that's yes so we have the
community
um but we actually have slack now which
is even better but before I go there
um we do have help and I don't want to
talk taunt the AI bot over here
um but you've got some self-service help
over here that you can do
um and go through a series of topics
um or if if it doesn't meet the topics
this is not like some of the the Bots
um right now I think I have to kick the
bot it's sleeping
um but there is you can actually create
a trouble ticket if you need to uh so
it's not just here's the five choices
and if it's not one of those five
choices too bad now you can actually
create a ticket
um and I'm not gonna panic yet because
this might just be like a let me log out
and log back in and and this might
actually work because I've been sitting
in this LMS for a little bit of time uh
so not going to get too worried about
that yet
um and here's slack right and I had to
resize it a little bit here I want to be
mindful of all of our Learners in these
various sessions
um but uh what you're seeing here of
course we talked about at the end of at
the end of a session you know this is
what we talked about this is what we're
going to talk about
um so again that's that you know if I
missed part of a class I can come back
and look and see what was covered
um and uh I I can see my other Learners
who would be contributing in here and
again I just tried to try to be mindful
of the Privacy so I'm I I'm not showing
the threads here but here's one of our
lsms as an example
um you know and we do you know have
direct messaging that you can send a
direct message via slack
um and and the other uh other really
cool thing there it is when I scroll
down to the bottom here you see these
links out here if you want to schedule
right you want to schedule office hours
you could do that you can schedule
office hour with our LSM you get to
schedule an office hour with myself I
keep it you know I do you know I'm you
know I I don't just teach
um I do have you know I'm Consulting I'm
working for clients uh you know sort of
day to day
um but I keep that calendar updated and
so sometimes I'll say you know at the
end of the class let's say if you want
to get to an office hour I've got
limited availability on this weekday uh
I've set it up so pretty much you you
can do a weekday you can do a week uh an
evening uh that we're not in class or
you could do a weekend that you'll
you'll click on that link and I already
had that calendar and it'll it'll send
me the invite and then we'll meet on a
one-on-one session uh to uh answer any
questions that anyone has
and I think I covered everything that we
were scheduled to talk about there
Stuart I think we covered all the
bullets maybe not in the exact order
yeah that's pretty good we hit
everything
and I just wanted to make one comment
about the past class recordings
sometimes you go to a class
you maybe look away for a moment and you
you miss a piece of the class or you
want to go back and
review what you learned in the class so
that you're sure you got it so it's not
just for the times that you miss a class
entirely it's also for the times that
you want to go back and review what was
discussed in class
um it's that's a really great feature
and you'll you'll get to see your own uh
contribution to the class when you watch
that recording so thank you very much
for that bill
appreciate that
um
and
back
we talked about the learning environment
the the live virtual classroom
environment
tests and assessments labs and projects
so you saw the the lab environment
um
there's not a Capstone project in this
course but there are the final modules
of red and blue team and you get to
track your progress so the system is
keeping track for you of where you are
and you can see your progress at any
stage see what it is you need to do to
complete the module you're in or get to
the next level
get to your final certificate and of
course we'll show the support tools of
you
um
Rick Hefner is the Caltech
ctme executive directories in charge of
Caltech ctme overall and he also
supervises this program so we're
very pleased that he gives the attention
to this program to make sure that we're
delivering curriculum they've defined in
uh the way that they want it set up
and
they certified that when you complete
the program and receive a certificate
they can put their name on the
certificate with confidence so
um
talk a little bit about learner outcomes
when you complete the Realtek
cyber security boot camp
you have access for six months to Career
assist services
uh these are through our partner Talent
Inc and
you get access to the job portal that
they offer this gives you a
separate way so you don't expose your
job search on places like indeed or
Glassdoor if if that's a concern to you
it protects your privacy but gives you
access to a number of exclusive job
listings
you also get help with your resume a
writer who collaborates one-on-one with
you does up to two rounds of revisions
to get your resume into the shape where
uh automated tracking systems and AI
Bots can recognize your skills and match
them up to job descriptions but also
remain
keep your resume attractive to the human
eye when it lands on someone's desk
uh and then one-on-one interview service
extremely valuable because you did to
practice with live people
different kinds of interviews you're
going to do from phone screens to
technical interviews to the cultural fit
interviews that you have to do
everybody has to do several rounds of
interviews to get a job these days and
so it's very important to have the
opportunity to practice those with a
live person so
this is available as I said six months
after you complete the boots
we'll talk about the program fees as we
get into how to get enrolled this
program is a flat ten thousand dollars
U.S it can be financed on equal monthly
installments of 881 a month
um and as I mentioned you receive a
bonus offer for attending today's
webinar if you join the next cohort so
reach out to us at ask us at
simplylearn.net to find out the details
the amount of that bonus offer
um
based on what we've told you so far are
you interested
in
enrolling in this program
and I'll leave this open for about 20
seconds
and uh 10 seconds I'll get your answer
in hit submit
I think the numbers are still changing a
little bit
and I will close the poll in three
two one
oh 87 percent of the folks who answered
said they would like to enroll
let me share with you how to do that
as I mentioned you'll want to
um
reach out to us
at ask us at simplylearn.net that is
I'll put that into the
email here or the chat rather
the two ways to contact us one is to go
through ask us at simplylearn.net one is
to go through our program webpage
uh in both cases you'll be able to
contact our learning Consultants who can
answer your question about
the discount available but also any
other questions you have about the
program
chat here
here we go
so in the chat now you have the email
address and the link to our program page
when you contact us they're just going
to there's not a lot of review in terms
of your work background or your
educational background you do have to
demonstrate that you have your high
school diploma or equivalent in the 18
years of age there will be some
questions evaluation of your aptitude in
math and programming but it's very
simple
uh not a rigorous test
you can start as soon as August 28th
so that's the next
formal cohort start
and
the induction session I think we
actually have induction sessions that
you can attend before
that and it's not the 2022 number it's
the 2023 number
um
but August 28th can
start the induction session get
the classes
and
we say hurry because
as
they'll describe
can't have more than a certain number of
people in the cohort in order for him to
be able to provide sufficient office
hours and assistance to individual
Learners so we try to limit our cohorts
to about 25 or 30 people tops
if you're interested in this August
cohort we recommend that you contact us
right away
and uh
Place reserved
um
but
pretty much what's necessary
bill to make sure that you have time to
deal with your students or the other
instructors have time to deal with
theirs
yeah we have we have a actually have
several cohorts running right now
um and and that's the idea is to make
sure that we have time
um and it's it's twofold it's during
class because if you get and like the
old school I still remember those old TV
shows of it's like a movie theater
stadium and they're trying to learn law
no one learns right no this is this is
your you're interacting in a smaller
group so you can ask questions just like
some of you are asking right now you can
ask questions and when it's a good time
we'll we'll get to those those answers
because sometimes they just come up in
the middle of a conversation uh but we
can if you're working on an exercise one
of the activities we can talk about that
um and yes then there's also the office
hours and having that availability that
um you know and and I think I'm not the
only one that we I believe we have other
trainers who are like myself working
professionals that you know they're
actively looking at these are the things
so if I make a joke about move it
um it's you know one of the best songs
from gas card but also a key
vulnerability that just came out two
weeks ago and everybody's worried about
it so we're literally bringing and
that's that's the other benefit of those
smaller classes is and that's office
hours like you said is yes we're we're
making sure we have time for the
Learners uh for those office hours but
then we're also when we're talking with
our Learners yes this is the breach that
just happened this week this is the
incident that just happened this is the
technology that's just coming down the
pike yeah and so it's it's not we're not
reading from textbooks by any stretch of
the imagination yeah the cohort
of Learners is one thing there's also
the cohort of trainers who are people
who like Bill have
industry experience and aren't just
talking to you about the theory but are
actually telling you about their
practice of cyber security
um so for those of you who are
interested are you looking at joining in
the August cohort are you looking at
joining further down the road
it's open for about
10 seconds longer
please let us know
and we always say that if it's something
that will change your life and career
for the better it's always worth doing
sooner than later
um
I'll close the poll in three
two one
and those of you who are looking to join
the August cohort that you'll definitely
be able to claim that Discount Contact
our learning Consultants about that for
those looking further down the road
uh contact us at ask us at
simplylearn.net and we'll keep track of
you keep you informed about future
cohorts as they come up and we'll also
answer any questions you have about the
enrollment process so
with that we can move on to our q a
and I'm going to stop sharing the screen
because we don't need to be staring at
this slide hold on for a second using
a second system to make sure we don't
problems with zoom on my primary system
um so we have some questions from the Q
a
uh first one is from a user raging soul
who says
do you think there's a strong
possibility of AI dominating cyber
security
sure yeah
how would there be proper audits for AI
well you know
the way I'm going to answer that
question is I'm hearing uh and this is
something you just you see this news and
you're like yeah AI will be very
confident but it will make up lies
yeah it will assert a lie and so will AI
dominate cyber security I think the
answer is going to be no uh because true
cyber security
uh true cyber security especially when
we get into ethical hacking requires
creativity that's a that's what a hacker
is a hacker is a creative person not
someone who is malicious but they're
curious and they're finding new ways of
doing things and AI is is it's doing a
good job but it's never going to replace
people it's never going to replace the
the people who are doing cyber security
and as far as audits for AI you know
it's funny you can also use AI against
Ai and there are our audit programs
being developed with that
it's interesting when you talk about
confidence and lying um
there was an AI generated uh paper
and I think you can look up the
reference in Google reference but the AI
generated academic paper and it turns
out
that the references it cited
were all invented by chat GPT to support
the argument that the paper was making
none of those papers that it cited
actually existed because chat GPT just
wants to create the something that is
following the form of what you ask it to
do and so if it doesn't have res if it
knows that an academic paper needs to
have citations of other papers and it
can't find those other papers it's going
to make up the citations to make it look
like
um what a real academic paper looks like
so again
AI has its own
problems in that respect it creates
other vulnerabilities and
it creates opportunities to both use it
as a tool and
treated as an emerging threat that
provides work for people to counter
um
when you talk about the basic
understanding of math and programming
you've talked a little bit about it in
terms of not understanding uh
programming from the point of how to
write statements in a particular
language but
understanding logic and on the math side
how what do people need to know or
understand to be able to
succeed in this program
um well you know it's uh can you perform
basic math without a calculator very
simple like the things we learned in
grade school I think is part of it uh
and and or if you have a calculator do
you know how to operate that calculator
um because yes we talk about binary to
hexadecimal and octal type conversions
but we show you how to do it and we also
show you how you do it in calculator and
if you can follow those steps that's the
and you logically can look at something
and go that doesn't look right or and
that's you know uh and like the Math
logic of you know how do you and this is
I guess a a consumer tip for everybody
now that there's this whole tip
phenomenon right how do you how do you
calculate a tip on something and you say
well you know okay 15 20 that's a number
you know well divided by five that that
that's not that hard I should be close
you know the the 100 divided you know
divided by five oh that's 20. okay right
so that's the idea of that math
skill okay thanks
um
we had a question uh
Katie Brown uh user asks about
opportunities for people 55 years and
older so the folks the white beards like
me
um
is this a field that people of this
generation can get into
absolutely
absolutely I the uh the 55 plus I you
know what
you can learn a new skill and what's
interesting and keep in mind with cyber
security especially you know if you're
looking for the solution engineering
solution architect one of the key skills
though sometimes those who have
experience in the industry
bring is their knowledge of a business
and business processes so now they can
align it with the technology of the
cyber security pieces uh and so yes that
transition absolutely is possible so you
could say oh I've been involved in uh
you know the financial services well now
you could transition to cyber security
and for those people like some if you
work for large Financial Services
organization you may be able to find
internal job postings and you're already
working there right and and I think a
lot of times we actually see some good
transitions because and I'll pick on
Financial Services because basically all
the financial institutions are closing
the brick and mortar branches so you've
got people who are
I have to find a job and well you know
what you could probably transition to a
cyber security role uh because you'd be
able to do an internal transfer
and you know you already know how that
organization works and one of the key
things about cyber security is that
you're supporting the business
so you understand a business so it it
definitely is an asset so for those
people who are 55 plus years of age no
you've got uh experience in business and
management and and it may be another
career but you can translate that and
now take the cyber security skills and
and pair them together yeah and the same
user has a question what are the
benefits of a cyber security career what
what do you find satisfying about it
what do I find satisfying well you know
um well obviously you get paid every
week
I gotta make you know what are the
benefits well that's one of the key
benefits people like right okay there's
there's we definitely like that
um but seriously
um the benefits of a cyber security
career uh is that it is changing and it
is not mundane and it is not the same
exact thing day after day after day and
that you know I say oh here's a preach
and here's a preaching here's a preach
but they're changing and so it's it's
not you know I I I'll quote that
advertisement it's not it's time to make
the donuts right it is not the same
thing that poor man who makes those
donuts it's the same thing every single
day and every single week and all he
gets is maybe it's gingerbread at
Christmas time right cyber security is
not that and that's that's why we do it
because it's fun because it changes
because it's growing and you're never
going to be sitting there going time to
reboot the servers there you go
um
I just want to say to minuti if you're
under 18 yes there will be future
cohorts so that when you um reach the
age of 18 you'd be able to check back
and join and uh
we had a question about getting the
recording we'll be sending an email out
after this webinar with a link to the
recording you expect that in a day or
two
um question about
um someone who's a military veteran has
held a top secret clearance I I myself
had it talk to secret clearance at one
time and um it's background in logistics
security so
you know my impression would be that
this is a person who understands
security and how vital it is to
organizations he'd be a good fit for
this would you agree with that
that's like you know he or she or they
yeah that's correct
um the uh absolutely the
um you're already familiar you have the
top secret clearance you understand
um and I'll say you you are an expert at
confidentiality uh that's usually what
we see in government military you know
how to shut people out now cyber
security you're going to mix in a little
bit of the integrity and the
availability
um you know I'm going to change you know
so it's going to be a little bit you
know transition air
um and I don't think they just give you
your secret clearance back or your top
secret back but you've been through the
process once before so it's not it's not
insurmountable uh the uh and you have a
great and some of the vendors or some of
the employers that we talked about we
talked about the Department of Defense
we had Lockheed Martin on that list uh
there's General Dynamics there's lydos
there's saic I you know you know
Accenture has Accenture uh Federal
Services yeah and all the individual
service branches uh have their own cyber
security organizations as well to not
just at the dod level so
um if you've worked in a particular
branch and you want to rejoin that
Branch capacity of cyber security as
maybe a civilian contractor
um
if you're past the point of being in the
Uniform service then certainly that's
that's a great opportunity for people
um and last question from Mir who asks
is there job placement
um I just want to refer you back to the
career job assist service that we
provide which is not placement it's not
a job guarantee but it is a set of
services that will help you with your
job search and prepare you and give you
access to Opportunities so
um we think it it helps maximize your
chance of success in the job search but
again not a placement or guarantee
program
so with that I'm going to go back and
ask
sent the last
part of our
really we're at the point where we say
thank you to bill for his
um
generosity with this time and his
knowledge
we'd want to ask if anybody would like
us to reach out
for assistance and enrollment
are you
if you answered yes we will contact you
directly
um
immediately
probably if you've indicated interest in
joining the program we'll probably
contact you as well but if you'd like us
to do that sooner than later please
answer yes
I will close this in three
two
one
so almost two-thirds not quite
two-thirds as answered that they would
like us to contact them directly so if
you answered yes you should expect to
hear from us very shortly
and otherwise you can contact us through
ask us at simplylearn.net
or through our website
take that off of your screen here
so with that I want to thank bill for
his
time his expertise for taking us through
the learning management system
really appreciate that Bill thank you so
much
absolutely thank you for having me
yeah we'll hope to see uh some folks on
a future cohort
wonderful
um if you want to use the QR code that
will take you to our webpage and
otherwise ask us at simplywin.net we'll
put you in touch with our learning
Consultants
we want to thank everyone who took their
time out this morning or if you're
outside of North America South America
uh for people who took their time out
this afternoon or evening we are
grateful to you for being here and we
look forward as Bill said to welcoming
you into the simply learn and Caltech
learning community
thank you so much and that concludes our
webinar